so 2019 call of duty modern warfare has
been out for a full weekend now and like
every year the hot takes are absolutely
flying I'm one hand you had shroud who
kicked off his first mixer stream with
the game and praised its gunplay but
then on the other hand you had prose and
casuals alike who were absolutely pissed
about it's annoying math design and then
you have Tim the tap man losing his mind
over 13 year olds clowning on him and
doctor disrespect went slightly insane
during his 24 hour live stream safe to
say it's been one crazy weekend okay
before we get into it this episode of
don't at me is brought to you by NVIDIA
GeForce now we all know guys that with
the game on the line frames win games
and NVIDIA has all the hardware you need
to unlock your full gaming potential so
for everything in video related make
sure to check out the links in the
description below now back to call of
duty so a lot of the talk surrounding
modern warfare this year involves around
getting back to the basics and well that
sounds like a gross marketing phrase in
practice it's actually pretty refreshing
no crazy operators or advanced movement
or stupid futuristic guns this time
we're back to boots on the ground with
realistic weapons and attachments
shooting people on realistic looking
maps and about those maps a lot of
people seem to hate them everything's
good with the maps maps are such a huge
thing dude most part of game could suck
but if there's decent maps I mean you're
in a good position not good
traditionally Cod's multiplayer maps
were tightly focused and had clearly
defined routes to run through this kind
of like pattern based style of map
encouraged memorization and it was a
part of the fast and fluid gameplay that
Cod was always known for like I wish I
was kidding when I say that I could
maneuver around high rise from mw2 with
my eyes closed
but I mean that was part of the fun
right but doing press prior to the
game's release developer Jeffrey Smith
talked about why infinity war was
switching up the map design a lot of map
design recently in cod has been more
symmetrical going to a modern warfare we
wanted to kind of keep that realism and
whenever you do symmetrical layouts it
really starts throwing people's brains
off I think humans can pick up patterns
really easily and so to make the space
feel real
you kind of really have to hide those
those three lanes and a lot of people
pros included aren't happy with the
changes
someone actually got paid to [ __ ]
make this map and then also got
co-signed by a bunch of other people who
are also paid to make man I think this
was [ __ ] good are you kidding me
now to me a guy who played an insane
amount of nw2 in high school the maps do
feel noticeably different for one thing
verticality is huge this year and
everything feels a little more cluttered
and while the three lane system is here
in theory it doesn't feel like you can
run laps around the maps anymore due to
this clutter and just the fact that
there's a ton more places to get shot
from in this title it doesn't seem to be
just the poor map design that has Cod
feeling less like Cod than ever before
in the last few iterations score streaks
replace kill streaks which encourage
playing the objective but now that kill
streaks are back playing four kills is
once again more important the sound
design is such that you can hear people
coming from a mile away
and with this new verticality in a
million corners to peak from Modern
Warfare this time feels super camp heavy
I'm getting super frustrated just
because you can't run around and try to
fry people in this game like at all like
obviously you don't want that all the
time right black ops 4 too fast you know
and too much mobility put this game
there's like absolutely zero mobility
even like cod four you could you know
destroy someone on ahead II like this
game there it seems like there's no
chance if someone's posted watching like
it's just a wrap you know from what I
can tell developer Infinity Ward have
been listening to player feedback since
just yesterday an update went live that
fixed a lot of the issues players were
having with the dead silence field
upgrades to be honest this iteration of
modern warfare feels more in line with
battlefield especially considering
there's a ground war mode that pits 64
players against each other in all-out
chaos now my favorite aspect so far have
been the smaller quality of life changes
you know being able to peek corners or
reload while aiming down the sights or
being able to edit your loadout
mid-match I have no idea whether or not
all of this is gonna be good or bad for
the cod eSports scene but with this new
look called duty world league right
around the corner we won't have to wait
long to find out they made a game that
caters to casual players but they're
hosting a league where teams paid 25
million
how to do it just shows that Activision
and the devs aren't synced up well I
mean I'm curious to see what happens
despite this lukewarm reception it is
still a fresh Call of Duty game which
means it dominated streaming platforms
this weekend and brought in big
viewership numbers for a lot of
different personalities for example on
Sunday skunk peaked at 34,000 viewers
almost double his average oh my god
somebody clip that the doc himself
peaked at almost a hundred thousand
viewers on Friday night when he kicked
off his 24-hour live stream but break it
through about get involved but wanting
it more and then of course there out who
peaked at seventy thousand viewers late
Thursday night once he managed to get
onto a server yes yes yes yes
with everyone comparing modern warfare
to previous titles a part of me wonders
why Call of Duty can't evolve and just
be different every year this sort of
thing happens with people complaining
that the newest title isn't like their
treasured favorite and I get it
nostalgia is real and there are tangible
issues with modern warfare but can't we
just like chill for a month before
writing this one off the other giant
change to multiplayer this year comes in
the form of a battle pass similar to
fortnight or Apex legends no loot boxes
no season pass this time around and map
DLC is apparently gonna be free another
giant change introduced this year is
cross play and so now you have console
PC going head-to-head for who's best and
then there's the standout gun fight mode
which is an intense 2v2 shooter with
randomized loadouts and a lot of anxiety
on my end but still there's a lot of
complaints
the underwhelming spawn system the lack
of mobility the fact that dead silence
isn't actually a perk in the super loud
footsteps yeah basically it's a new game
and people have their issues despite all
of this people seem to be having a ton
of fun with the game you got the likes
of ten the top man dr. Lupo and cloak si
teaming up for a bunch of shenanigans in
ground war great
and of course you got trout doing what
trout does best there we go I got it
overall it seems like the sentiment
about this year's Call of Duty's fairly
normal a lot of people hate it a lot of
people think it's fine and some people
think it's great
the biggest issue that's probably gonna
dominate the conversation in the next
couple of months is the seemingly poor
map design in its impact on the
competitive scene and seeing how
Activision are launching this new cod
franchise League in 2020 who knows what
the hell is gonna happen and hey there's
also a campaign which I'm thoroughly
enjoying like a total loser and once
again shout out to NVIDIA GeForce for
helping us put this video together and
for everything you need to know about
them make sure to check out the links in
the description below thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]